thank you
[Music]
all right the crazy thing is I've pulled
this article out and I was like man this
is hilarious and I didn't think it was
going to be such big news and as I was
driving here this morning it was all
over the radio really so you predicted
well it's actual news so unfortunately
this video is going to be uploaded in
like 60 years but or topic it'll be a
throwback put a hot topic on it or maybe
count will delete it
so we don't know it'll be too tempted I
like the idea of Throwbacks
I love how cats in the other room he's
like oh this is a popular one
I like to think that can copies the
videos and then deletes them just
cathartically to get that little rush
oh my God
dopamine oh yeah he [__] hates us
dude all right so there's a plane right
Delta Airlines flight that was going
from Atlanta to Barcelona
no right and two hours in they had to
turn around and go back to Atlanta
because of a [__] extreme diarrhea
accident what happened everybody wants
to know what happened I want pics who
was it pics it's extreme too yeah like
what was extreme listen to this uh how
many days ago was it this was this is
last Friday I always thought it was like
you don't turn the plane around unless
it's life or death this is a turnaround
everybody was dry heaving probably
people were probably yeah
vomiting chain reactions
so that's the guy who did it though yeah
it smells pretty good so listen to the
uh this is the audio this is the flight
audio yes flight audio and you can see
the pathway here of them turning all the
way around to go back
to had diary all the way through the
airplane so they wanted to come back
all the way through the air oh you know
what I think happened he [__] himself
and then the poopoo dragged all over the
floor yeah imagine him like sprinting to
the bathroom and just not being able to
make him every step is just
there's a video of the have you do you
see the video of the aftermath on that
one I've blurred photos I'll go to the
link on my thing you can see it is this
like you know remember that M Night
Shyamalan movie Unbreakable yeah we're
like they're real superheroes out there
and you see like examples through news
stories is this like I mean this guy had
a blowout throughout the entire plane
like this guy's like a [__] X-Man
somewhere in the world there's a guy who
just never [__] at all and then there's
him no there's yeah no I'm saying this
guy has like a superhuman ability to
[__] himself crop duster dude yeah dude
said that like um it's it's uh you guys
have ever had that explosive diary it's
like a real clinical thing I think every
time I have diarrhea it's explosive this
one particularly they said it's like
when you're uh your intestines are like
pushing so hard and spasming that it's
like filling up the your rectum to the
point where it's like it's like loading
hella shells and and then once you're
shooting
it's like putting your thumb over a hose
I think it's slightly different every
time I have diarrhea it's like when you
lift up the toilet seat it's on the
bottom because it's splashed down yeah
yeah dude I'm talking about every time
it's either I don't have diarrhea or I
do
and when you have diarrhea you guys have
gentle diarrhea yeah
he pulls out yeah yeah I think there's
leaky and then I think there's explosive
yeah there's the explosive feels like a
fart with
spray yeah there's been times when I
pull my [__] sticks down in the back
of the toilet seat get [__]
paintballed yeah I think there's a
difference where if it drops directly
down because it's leaky and the splash
comes up versus like it's shot laterally
yeah mine's that one mine's either I
think solid
or like like a [__] confetti like
yeah you're you're an all or nothing but
maybe maybe the explosive diarrhea is
more about also the spray but also the
volume of poop you know that's what I'm
saying like what the [__] how did this
guy cover the entire plane that's why I
think he asked me and they've got two
bowls of Pho before and didn't cook the
bean sprouts enough
did you see the video it's on a it's
like a Twitter link Twitter link yeah
there's a it shows the aftermath of when
the plane got de-boarded and they're
they're showing the hallway oh it really
is it's bad so it was a problem so do
you think from that video you would be
dry heaving if you were on that plane oh
diarrhea above water smells crazy
above sea level did you know that the
plane Air is just recycled they don't
bring in new oxygen so they said they
tried they said they tried to put a
vanilla there's a quote that says like
oh they try to put a vanilla scented
like odorizer to like help deal with it
and the the person goes it just ended up
smelling like vanilla [__]
and then open the personal whiskeys and
start dumping it on the carpet some
alcohol you gotta get rid of all that
alcohol that's [__] crazy dude
what airline was it Delta Delta oh there
it is yeah Delta you felta Delta you
felt I can't believe the pilot also said
diarrhea what were you supposed to say
feces
everywhere you know why because it says
that uh when it's specifically diarrhea
that would ever cause a diarrhea could
get transmitted to the other people oh
like a stomach if it's E coli or if it's
um salmonella like it's a file Hazard
there we go
so you'll just see remnants and we'll
get this video out to you as well
um you could see just them throwing uh a
bunch of paper towels or something
yeah oh wow
oh
god what the [__] get the [__] out of
here dude
that's Hershey's dark chocolate and and
you know that they got the extra Comfort
Seats in that area too premium economy
guys that's correct
you paid extra Comfort dude if there's
any moment where someone deserves
anonymity I hope this person keeps you
yeah can you imagine that this guy just
had a diarrhea situation that was
terrible but it's also like notorious
and all over the news the next morning
yeah I feel like they should also be
banned from the air air from flying no
fly list
maybe like a year well I don't know it's
like the bathrooms are kind of close
though in a plane because I actually
[__] myself a couple weeks ago during
Mercury retrograde
what please continue yeah that's why I
asked when this happened because I maybe
it was a Mercury retrograde thing
related yeah all of us kind of [__]
ourselves at the same time but how did
you [__] yourself
I thought I had enough time because it
was about 15 minutes to drive home I
dropped off Hannah at the YWCA she was
doing some [__] volunteerism right
and then I felt my guts going oh
Vietnamese coffee and the same thing you
just ordered all right but I haven't had
IBS in like years I've been okay
so I just felt like maybe I had a fart
and then like
um you know had a little fart you played
with fire I know but the fart was fine
it was just a fart okay but then my
stomach started hurting again and I was
like what the [__] I just shot before I
ate breakfast
and then I had to start speeding yeah
because you know up your pants at that
point well at that point my music is
blasting you're focusing I'm doing
breathing exercises oh I gotta turn the
music down my ass yeah I gotta Focus
dude I gotta like I have to focus I
can't be like quite like I just have to
be hyped like I'm per like you know I
gotta move you start dancing yeah I did
the thing where you're driving on one
ass cheek because you're trying to
clinch
oh yeah and then yeah and every minute
I'm counting it down and I'm like [__]
bro this is gonna [__] kill me
driving the the left lane or the right
lane
I was on the highway did you put the
emergency I was weaving in and out
because if I need to really go out on
the right people are like exactly I'm
ready to just jump out of the car and
just spray it on the wall oh no I was
weaving in and out I was weaving in and
out different mentality I got it I was
fine up until the driveway I got there
and I don't have a [__] key I have
this stupid goddang app that unlocks
remotely so I got up I [__] unlocked
the remote it doesn't have a panic mode
but then I pushed the wrong button and a
[__] ad came up and I was like God
damn god what the [__] and I turned it
off the [__] door finally opened when
in there [__] threw everything down
and as I was running up my roommate was
like cooking [__] in the kitchen and
then I was just like [__] trying to
Sprint and three steps before the
bathroom I just felt that [__] just leak
out oh no it went one two and as soon as
I went down like that it was three and
on the way out it was my underwear it
was all my shorts it was so [__] up
dude oh no that's disgusting all over
the toilet seat all over all over the
back side everything it felt like a
public restroom and then I was sitting
there going like [__] there's [__] all
over me right now dude and he's just
like Hannah
someone's gonna pick her up no one's
home right and the whole time I'm
thinking [__] dude what am I gonna do
and then I was like all right cleanup's
the worst what's the yeah because I felt
so much better but the cleanup in his
stank like [__] and I'm there with my
pants around my ankles and there's Kaka
right there there's Cocker on the
[__] see [__] everyone I don't want
to [__] move did you crack on the rug
no thank god dude and then imagine oh my
God and then imagine my pants caught it
God did this my pants caught it wait so
why do you want to punish this guy for
what happened no Joe's giving us like a
POV of what that guy must be feeling I
have important contacts so he had he had
time
did he it's three it's three steps to
the back yeah he's sitting there the
whole time I unlock a thing and see a
hello fresh yeah okay I had 15 minutes
dude
it's two hours into the flight right
yeah I was two hours into the flight
yeah so they already put their [__]
seats back dude everyone they should bat
them
or he was following the leave your seat
belt on the act of terrorism 20 minutes
after takeoff all true unless it was a
crazy turbulence thing but even then
like if you know I Break The Rules what
if you're window seating it and then you
got two sleepy [__] next to you and
then you're like oh okay that is okay
step on the armrests and walk over I
think your p is one thing if you know
you're about to explode your bowels
that's different like that look at this
context uh it said uh both passengers
and crew members were subsequently
transferred uh and the fight eventually
made it to Barcelona at 5 10 p.m the
next day a whole eight hours later than
originally scheduled according to data
you know what's crazy after they uh
landed the plane in five hours I think
the ground crew ripped the carpet out
and installed new carpet whoa they move
quick that's so fast yeah like therapy
for everybody involved like that's an
insane what a way to start your vacation
lawsuit absolutely isn't that pretty
crazy though that that happened quite
some time ago and they still haven't
leaked the identity of the person they
haven't like the identity thank you dude
so it's it's gonna get leaked somehow
there's some down ass uh passengers on
that plane
is a marketing campaign for Delta
they're just like check out our [__]
response time
does this also kind of give like
terrorists ideas though
they could just eat a bunch of crazy
food and just and just [__] diarrhea
all over the place they'll turn the
plane around yeah they go to Chili's
Americans will turn it around right yeah
they want to ruin people's flights if
you just see a [__] Middle Eastern
guys eating [__] ton of flaming hot
Cheetos in the [__] plan you'll know
what the hell he's up to now yeah if you
see a middle eastern go out of Ruby
Tuesday it's call the police
what do you think this guy ate at the
air which which airport restaurant did
this guy eat at prior
I'm I'm going Sparrow
yeah I think he ate some hot wings yeah
I think he did a hot wing challenge he's
at Popeyes dude the news the newsstand
sandwich yeah he was he was at Duncan
and he got a little too carried away
dude they don't have a picture of the of
the guy who did this but they do have a
picture of some of the passengers coming
out oh no that's pretty wild insane
thank you